well let's go live now to dublin where
we can speak to the chief executive of
ryanair michael o'leary michael good
morning to you
you've just announced your cutting
capacity by a fifth this month and next
clearly the recovery hasn't been as good
as you hoped
good morning i think that's true uh the
aviation industry across europe has been
bedeviled by government mismanagement of
uh travel restrictions and quarantines
uh we keep pointing to the example of
italy in
germany who have returned to uh safe
intra-eu
air travel since the first of july by
managing much more
much lower covert case rates in britain
or ireland
they have a much more effective test and
tracing system than britain or ireland
and you know our industry and our
customers
are struggling to make any bookings with
confidence when you have
for example the british government
locking down bolton one day
preston another day inventing this new
restriction that
social settings will be reduced to six
people like
they're just making this stuff up as
they go along as a
uh to cover up the fact that the test
and tracing is effectively non-existent
in the uk is the uk then the most
problematic of all your markets i mean
you're a big pan-european carrier but do
you think the uk government is
significantly worse than governments
elsewhere
no i mean to be fair i would rank the
irish government is by far and away the
worst uh
even as the rest of europe opened up to
air intra-eu air travel on the 1st of
july
the irish government which has abrogated
all management released to a bunch of
medics and civil servants called nephit
and we've kept ireland completely locked
up
i think we're only allowed we're not
even allowed to travel to the uk
despite the fact that people can travel
across the border with northern ireland
with no restrictions
so we've had ireland completely locked
up since the first of july
no tourists are welcome we're closed for
business we can't send any of our people
to the uk or germany for example to meet
airports without quarantine
for 20 for 14 days and despite that
ireland has
one of the highest and fastest writing
covert case rates in europe
now we think by the way that the focus
on covert case rates is completely
misplaced
uh because what's evident in the second
wave is that
rising covert case rates is not
translating into hospitals being
overwhelmed or icu's being flooded with
people
in ireland our hospitals and icus are
essentially empty
and yet we are pandering to this uh
covent case rate nonsense and
while at the same time the germans and
the italians have been allowing intra-eu
air travel since the first of july their
covet case rates are about half that of
the uk
and ireland of ireland uh the uk is
uh reasonably low as well and yet
we still have these bizarre restrictions
in the uk for example
they're locking down regions like bolton
and preston but then they say nobody can
travel to spain despite the fact that in
spain
while there are high covert case rates
in the main cities of barcelona and
madrid
there are no covent case rates in the
canaries the lyrics in the tourism
uh hot spots so there's no common sense
and the industry is calling for more
effective testing at airports that at
least
would help us to continue to deliver
safe air travel we've been you know
doing that since the first of july
ourselves
um and we're also calling on the
government to um you know
reduce apd the travel attacks on air
travel
if richie sunak who cleverly came up
with a
you know eat out to help out scheme uh
gave people 50 reductions on their meals
why haven't they reduced apd in the uk
which is still
a an unfair and egregious tax but
that stops people visiting the uk
michael i just want to pick up on what
you said about airport testing there
because of course boris johnson's ruled
it out on the grounds of airport tests
only pick up seven percent of cases
that's true but i mean boris johnson if
you look at his record on covet has been
lamentable you know he ruled out uh
wearing face masks originally he was
running around shaking hands with
everybody he's consistently called the
entire covert pandemic wrong
you know we were the people who were
that were criticized when we announced
were going back flying on the first to
die with mandatory face mass
at a time when boris johnson was
allowing people into london underground
without mandatory face mass so
boris johnson and his government have
been consistently
late to the party and wrong on covet
so frankly i wouldn't take any advice or
guidance from him
the thing is that testing at the airport
it helps
it provides more certainty and it's a
lot better than simply saying
we're banning people traveling to spain
we're banning people arriving from spain
huge volumes of the spanish population
are not suffering from covet
and therefore there's no reason to ban
them you're in greater danger of
catching covet in bolton than you are in
barcelona
so these bands are completely effective
now looking at
your business you successfully raised
850 million euros on the bomb market
yesterday you've also done a share
placing raising another 400
million euros for people who want to up
to speed on that why have you raised all
that money this is not to shore up
what's already a fairly healthy balance
sheet this is fairly opportunistic is it
well we have a very healthy balance
sheet in but we have two major debt
repayments next year we have to repay
the uk government
uh loan of 600 million in march and we
have our a 2016 bond of 850 million
that's due for payment in june
um and so you know the equity rates last
week of 400 million is less than three
percent of our equity and the bond rates
yesterday is a way of making sure that
we have
solidly pre-financed those debt
repayment obligations next year
we do have three and a half billion
still sitting on the balance sheet but
there's no doubt as governments continue
to mismanage
air travel and these travel restrictions
i think we're facing into a terrible
winter
the likelihood is that the situation is
going to get worse
there will be more mismanagement and
more ineffective government regulations
and so
i think we have to be cautious we need
to jealously protect
our cash reserves there will be a virus
found for this vaccine ryanair will
respond will return whereas the fastest
growing most profitable airline
but only once a vaccine has been found
so the reason we raised the money in the
last week has been so that we can
guarantee
and pre-fund those debt repayments next
year
briefly michael your agm is coming up
the shareholder advisory group
iss has told investors to vote down your
bonus what have you got to say to that
i think it's remarkable given that
firstly my bonus was cut in half
uh i've reduced my salary by 75 this
year
and i know the iss the chief executive
iss doesn't even publish
his salary or his bonus figures so i
think these
uh proxy firms should be much more open
about what they're paying their chief
executives
before they sit start criticizing ceos
like me who've taken a 75
pay cut and a 50 bonus cut in the
current pandemic
i'm leading the way while these proxy
firms
hide and cover up what they're paying
their chief executives which is many
times
more than i'm paid i think a lot of ceos
will be uh cheering you on there michael
good to talk to you thanks for joining
me
you two ian god bless